to three even aronia
if he wins this game with the white
pieces
it's obviously four four and that would
mean two more games
would be played if magnus carson does
not lose this game
he wins the match and the event
c4 b5 ram move here everybody
plays e6 first agnes carson
freestyling in
in the night of 5 rook a7
not typically how people play
a4 aronian going
for direct action before knight a2 if e6
what's the point bishop c6 check or
knight c6
e6 plate we shall see probably knight c6
i don't think it's bishop b3 no he goes
bishop c6
now bishop d7 you can't take
since after takes takes
both the rook and the queen will be an
attack
but bishop d7 knight before d5 looks
like a nice counter by the world
champion
targeting the knight on b4 if the knight
is defended whatever let's see
bishop takes d7 followed by c3 direct c3
black can always regain this pawn with a
good position
so the opening
looks like it went pretty well for
magnus e5 it's russian suk
he doesn't want to take here allowing
knight takes e4 or d
d takes e4 goes e5
giving magnus a choice which piece to
retain and how he goes bishop ce5 ef
queen f6
it should be three e5
yeah mine is better
is the term for intermediate move it's
the german words but it's also used in
english
chess lingo so in case you were confused
because i read a lot of
lol social suicide it means intermediate
move
like pawn to e5
you don't capture but you throw in
different little move
act forceful three saying that that
sound that man makes
is german is my first language and
sushen suk is a german word
i choose to pronounce it correctly sorry
if that bothers you
as for the game
pawns are equal the white
knight has a very nice square in the
center of the board
[Music]
i don't know anything can happen
which 4.36
3-3 plate going back to d8 whoa can't be
not happy
knight f5 can't be not happy either
short castles we have to go back to this
and investigate
stuff like this about 95 short castles
position on the board
now queen g4 will threaten checkmate not
g6
shortcut long cast is 95 queen takes a6
now why does it pawn up but the king is
sort of
weakish queen b8
targets this knight t3 is there can't do
it yet because of rope d3
b6 is an option incredibly sharp
position
we also became also become a game of
attrition here
players must be tired playing two
matches today
rook f2 a7
still very sharp knight d3 wins the
exchange you could go knight d3 rook d3
and then sergeant suk queen takes b5 a
takes b5
he takes d3 but that position i'm not
sure if black is better because
there would be a passport on b5 knight
could cover it all
so yeah i don't know
my t3 plate here we go and carson does
not capture on b5
it takes directly
get 4 by rolling preparing
for potential end games
engine says black is winning to my mind
this is
completely unclear anything could happen
g6 plate
and the knight didn't have any good
squares so knight h6
king g7
knight to g4
nick wisconsin
can end this match with the draw if he
loses it continues
on to f5 once again not
the computer's favorite move he's trying
to stop knight to f6
and aronian goes quince c5
what's going on f3 f3 rook of 8 at this
point
but at the very least
black should not lose there's no queen
f8 queen a7 king h6
then the queen can start getting checks
and aronia does resign magnus carlsen
wins the san fermin mundial
final 5'3 in the end became a very
tense match